very uh strong economic growth numbers
uh
for for this year the strongest for for
decades maybe you know since the
invention of gdp
how would you characterize them is this
is this a boom we're in at the moment or
something else
well i think two two sort of reflections
on it one
i mean it is it is a very strong
recovery and
you know thank goodness in a way because
of what we went through last year
um with with an unprecedented falling
activity in the economy
so that's the good news that it is a
strong recovery i think
you would expect a central bank
government to say this i mean the
caution is of course that what it does
is take us back in terms of the level of
activity in the economy
we think by the end of this year to
where we were
at the end of 2019 i.e pre-covered
so very good news on on
the recovery but i'm afraid we do have
to sort of put it into perspective
and say if we get back to where we were
in 2019 by the end of this year
that is still two years with no growth
in it when you look at
you know the long-term growth horizons
still
after this very strong growth in this
year and pretty strong growth
next year as well it's still relatively
weak
number in 2023 so
you know has the kind of long-term trend
growth rate
our ability to grow in this economy
potentially being damaged
by covid where we were always heading
for that weakness
well in many ways of course uh where we
get back to on that projection is where
we were before with a relatively weak
uh long-term longer-term trend rate of
growth
you know the trend rate of growth has
fallen over the last for 20 30 years
you know i remember in sort of you know
when i was you know supporting much
policy committee in its early days we
always used to think around about two
and a quarter percent was probably a uk
trend rate of growth and of course it's
been lower than that
uh certainly since the financial crisis
so i think
where is it now would you say trend
growth one one and a half one
it's probably somewhere around one and
three quarters you know not more than
that probably
um and that's that must be borrowing
long term
yes um and i think that brings us back
to i mean
two reflections on that one of the
key things that we need to look at going
forwards is you know what we can do to
raise productivity growth
uh and to do that i think we've got to
look at both you know private and public
investment
because we've had very weak productivity
growth since the financial crisis
we've had variable investment over the
periods
period now one thing that should benefit
that investment
there is a relationship between the
level of uncertainty people have an
investment because it's always
you know in a sense as an incentive to
to delay and wait
lower uncertainty you know relates to
kovid and brexit should help in that
respect
but another real big reason why raising
the trend rate of growth
is important is is of course is how we
deal with managing the inherited
burden of debt from covid it will be
much easier
to manage that both for companies and
for government by the way
to manage that debt burden with stronger
underlying growth
but just in terms of the economic
forecast um
one analogy might be 1927. there was
quite a big bounce back after the
general strike
um and in the sense that was kind of an
enforced shutdown of parts of the
economy and then it bounced back
but i wonder you know if that analogy
might lead people to think oh
are we in for another roaring twenties
after we've even got through this
uh with all of this fiscal monetary
impetus so
going around the economy so what do you
see out there well because one of the
interesting things about
much of the 1920s is they didn't
actually have uh perhaps
supportive and loose fiscal and monetary
policy actually i mean because it was a
obviously a big uh you know big move to
get back onto the gold standard not not
necessarily one of the better decisions
in the history of the
history of british economic policy so i
don't think i don't think the analogy in
that sense
is sort of particularly you know what i
mean the things that it's a waste of the
races now people spending all those
savings and so on well i think
you could sort of generalize the point
say you know once you get into a habit
will it all get out of hand
um i don't think there's any reason to
believe that at the moment but look we
will be watching this very carefully you
can take that for granted